[Applause]
thank you
you grow slow in your old age circus
bro
if it you you'll not share
I've been in your Shadow for hours but
since nothing
pathetic
laughs
I asked for an equal
and this is what you find
sir
perhaps
a new hunting ground
[Music]
[Applause]
light the fires
the great hands begins
[Music]
thank you
this is cited in Queens closing in now
cover the door
could be anywhere
you have no idea
leave Connor alone
to hunt I'll give him one he'll never
forget
he's gonna wish he never came to New
York
triangulating positions
Target located at Harlem Fish Market all
teams converge lizards across the river
I'm not gonna make it in time
[Music]
miles the hunters tracked Connors to the
Harlem fish market
wizard
I'm on it sounds like Craven's shutting
off his we don't have much time move
uh guess we'll chat later
Genki the lizard's loose at the fish
market must be Sushi night you still got
that Hunter drone you hijacked and
really tough hiding it from my mom but
yeah I'll I'll boot up and see you there
they got here fast
[Music]
can't let them find Connor's
more reason for it
[Music]
spread out if you find them isn't don't
engage alone
look at those fish it's been feeding
we ever saw it coming
[Music]
so how's the hunt going
by the three tons of dead fish not well
where are you Connors
garage my Lee tomb
Connors tore through this place
trolls
thank you
[Music]
where am I now
how'd you find me follow the fish
drones picking up lizards Trail
he's still eating we can catch him off
guard
Yankee get behind me
it's just his skin
doesn't that mean he's getting bigger
hungry here too
amen
new threads the building's swarming with
Hunters any sign of Connors uh yeah
Yankees tracking him hey Mr Parker
I mean
but the date is incomplete
that wasn't me me neither
I don't even have a stomach so
let's go
go go make him alive
can't lose counters Harry's dying and
he's the only one who can help we won't
you take the Drone I got the jet skis
well if I borrow this
boy this is really really exciting give
it tight man watch out for those drones
don't worry they think I'm a friendly
each river is not a river but in fact
the saltwater title flat but Spider-Man
you're fighting on right now
help the door vote right I've got the
metal murder bird
I warned you about going after Connor's
now this is on you
clouds that all you got
almost done here civilians are all safe
how you looking
ship won't quit I'm right behind you
we'll take it down together no time
I got you time to go boom boys no no no
Spider-Man is good defenses
Spider-Man hang on
over there
[Music]
hmm
come on let's go
it's right behind you I know I know whoa
Steve Master fly faster
I do not want to be lizard food
thank you
okay
hold on
everyone take cover
what are you guys doing trying to take
out that gunship can't get close enough
but I can't I'm one of them remember bro
that's it hey alley-oop on three pi
one two three Ally
foreign
I saved the tracker
let's go man before he gets too far no
it's mine
sure
it's got big teeth
so do I
um he's not normally like that right
no
he's never like that
[Applause]